listening to phil
and Kerry Wood
you know there's a lot of people doing
creative things here in LA you know
where there's a lot of filmmakers a lot
of people trying to and and the and and
so disjointed disconnected and it's like
and very competitive and it's like you
know to you know I don't care what
you're working on and I hope you don't
succeed because I want my thing to work
and that that doesn't that doesn't work
that doesn't really fly you know what
what works better is is hey we're part
of a community here and we can all lift
each other up you know because you know
your success could open the doors for my
project also you know and that's and
that's yeah and i think the the a the
idea that we can have a collective
screening of an independent movie once a
month and i'll hang out meet and talk
afterwards without feeling like this is
I've got to pitch my project here I've
got a I've got to convey how like a
great I am that's just a great
atmosphere for people to come together
so I was really impressed by the the
concept behind it and what you're doing
and I'm looking forward to the next one
that's essentially you know what it
takes when you go you know I I believe
in the story I'm committed to it I'm
going to make this movie I'm going to
make it happen so deliverables if you
don't if you're not you know don't
understand the technical elements of
what needs to be manufactured and
created in order to bring the film into
distribution team up with someone you
know that's team up with someone who
does understand them whether it's an
editor or a producer or someone who's
like yeah you know we're going to need
our separate audio tracks and we're
going to need some artwork we're going
to need this is what these are the
things we're going to have to build also
that go beyond just shooting the actors
interacting and telling the story